And then what's Sean that's sugar.
Shauna's as but it's way more than that.
He makes more than that.
So what is fortnight you can somebody explain fort night to me?
I'm sorry I was still in far cry.
Five any third person shooter,
you're jumping around shooting.
Be Bold with third person shooters.
Like is it a story or is it just like you're,
you know,
you got other people people up.
I think the story is really just drop it in to survive.
Oh,
there's no campaign mode or if there's cancer is,
but that's a separate,
yeah,
that's not what,
it's interesting to me about fortnight.
The graphics suck.
I don't want you and me,
that's a graphic style.
But those that,
that it has to uh,
Xbox to,
somebody had a,
a,
an image and it was from 2007 it had said,
man,
look at this.
I wonder what video games are going to be looking like.
The graphics going to be looking like in 2018 and then it shows fortnight and
it's like,
this is like,
dude,
there's like,
they've turned the textures off.
They 100%.
You turn the textures off when you play online,
if you don't have a powerful enough computer,
sure you don't claiming.
Right.
So it doesn't make you streaming.
It doesn't make your video game.
Video card works so hard,
but also it makes it easier to recognize shapes because they're not as like that
was the thing that he did with quake.
They would completely turn the textures off when guys would be like playing in
high level matches and you would just deal with these flat walls and then the
object,
the person that you were fighting against wood,
they would stand out and start contrast.
Right,
right.
So you didn't have,
you know,
otherwise you'd be in this castle wall,
you'd have the incredible textures on the wall and you wouldn't be able to see
them as easily distracting.
That's what I think.
I think I love about video games too.
He's like,
you know the scenery.
Sometimes I just want to stop and be like,
that's it.
The right side has full graphics is not,
so it depends on what is reasonable.
I mean it still is a little bit,
you know,
that's not much different.
At all.
Yeah.
I mean sort of the left side is just dark.
There's grass.
Yeah.
Look at the graph building.
There's still some movement on the ground.
It's not flat plain like it isn't quick.
Go to quake it play,
go to quake three,
no textures.
Make a video or a pull up a video of that and you'll see what I'm talking about.
What I'm talking about is like literal flat walls where people turned everything
off and it got to a point where they weren't allowing it and certain
competitions because it makes such a big difference because now you're just
like,
it's a target in front of a blank screen.
You can also replace all of the characters with a larger character like uh,
like say if you were playing,
I was like this girl,
so I get this one.
It's showing the mod in between.
Maybe I'm thinking,
I'm sorry.
I'm really quick.
Like I've heard of air you son of a pitch,
so no,
no.
Jamie pull,
pull up,
quake,
no textures,
pull up,
quake,
no textures and then you could watch what it looks like.
That is not,
no textures,
that that's different.
You could see the difference in the colors and things are moving.
It's when they turn off all the,
you,
you get to see these flat well that's what it looks like.
Seat.
Yeah.
Now that is a way different experience.
It would be much easier to get to see.
Right.
You can't shut those still exist,
but all the textures are gone.
Yeah.
And if you show a video that,
see if you could find a video of that Jamie,
when,
uh,
in the videos you see things moving around with no textures and you realize what
an advantage it would be if you were playing someone who's,
you're,
you're constantly dealing with all this visual input.
You have all this different shit.
High visibility.
It's hard to find out who is this,
which games this quake live.
Oh,
okay.
This is again,
I still got to ask what is quick.
I mean,
I know I've heard of it,
but I've never played it.
Like it's the ultimate first person shooter and it's the original one.
It was originally quake one and well there was doom but it was doom.
I've heard of like I've even their they days we did doom didn't pay.
They came out with another,
didn't they come out with another version of Dune?
Yes they did.
And there's another one that's coming out soon.
Um,
but what quake one was was these cool maps and you would run around and shoot
each other and you'd have these death matches.
So one on one death matches and shoot rockets at each other and shit.
And you're seeing it through your perspective.
Like,
so if you have a rocket launch,
you see the rocket launcher in front of you there at that whole idea.
What does this one,
oh,
this is quake champions.
This is the newest version.
I mean the graphics are fucking incredible on these things now they,
they're so excited.
We're going to have,
we're setting up a lamb here,
a local area network here.
What we're going to stream,
live and play each other.
Excellent.
And a waste massive amounts of time.
And I'm sure I'm going to Yell Dad.
Sometimes I'm sorta like,
oh,
three hours just went by.
He's going to go to sleep a little bit.
Oh,
well whatever,
dude,
it will suck up your time,
but then you know I can't play.
I'm just,
I'm not good enough to play those kinds of things like it's just like spawn,
die,
spawn guy you to figure out how to do it.
You're a smart guy.
How dare you say that?
You put the limitations.
We can't do that.
Listen,
we just need to learn left w a s d learn how to move your fingers around now I
need the soles are bullshit.
I got some people say it can't get any real accuracy with a console.
That's your problem.
The finger,
the type,
I mean the console.
Now I'm thinking I could send it to you.
How do you learn physics?
How do you,
what is that?
All this fucking
movie.
We were like,
you can do it man,
you can.
It's like rocky or something that's ready.
Karate kid or whatever.
How ever done that for video games,
who'd never been that movie where he still is?
Someone teaches someone how to play a video game nerd in the beginning and he's
like a loser,
but you know,
it comes back and he gets the girl.
Well,
one of the reasons why I wanted to talk to you about this in particular is
because I am more and more convinced that it's our future may lie in some
artificially created world and that people are more interested in more attracted
everyday to virtual reality,
augmented reality,
virtual reality.
And what can Jamie,
what was that game?
That one game where,
um,
there was,
uh,
the,
it created worlds.
I was going to pull that up earlier and ask,
it's called no man's sky.
Oh,
I played that.
I played the,
I bought it because of course any space game.
I'm like whoring though.
It is because you know,
they have 80 trillion worlds,
but they're all,
they're basically,
they don't look that different,
you know,
so it's like oatmeal,
80 million bottles and over there you could go there and people are shooting
each other and stealing money.
No,
no.
What is better for that?
Oh yeah.
Right.
I mean it's,
you know,
it looked like it was people,
but what's better is I'm elite,
dangerous.
So after this I was so disappointed in this,
uh,
I went back and I found a leap dangerous,
which actually just disappointing this cause there was no action.
Yeah,
there was no,
you just ran around in your mind stuff.
It was sorta like,
it just wasn't exciting.
There was nothing exciting.
There was no,
you know,
there was no,
so I,
like I said,
I don't usually play sort of these massive multiplayer games.
So this is elite,
dangerous,
elite,
dangerous end.
It is man the trading or you know,
you could decide like,
oh,
I want to be a,
I want to be a bounty hunter,
you know?
Um,
and it was so rich.
I just,
I spent,
there was like a good six months in my life that I was like,
you know,
working my way,
getting better ships.
That became,
because you're like,
who doesn't want to be a bounty hunter?
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
that's what everybody's,
and this just this game had,
you know,
and there's like,
I don't know,
a few hundred thousand people in there.
You're creating the universe.
It's evolving.
They add storylines.
So,
you know,
well we are setting up an HTC vive here and uh,
we're,
we,
Jamie was HTC vibe.
How dare you.
I know,
man.
It's like,
you know,
that's a copy yourself dork you call your [inaudible].
Um,
they never not have sex.
Virtual reality.
It's,
and it's a consumer virtual reality.
When my friends never done,
Ooh boy.
I know.
I've been waiting.
I've been sort of,
well we tried to get one.
Jamie went out yesterday and look,
they're all sold out.
So we had to order one and so we're ordering one,
we're going to have it set up in here.
Um,
and the,
uh,
the games I played the games of two years ago and I'm sure they're way more
advanced than they are now.
There's a crazy archery game where the,
you're on a top of a castle and these little monsters that look like they could
be in south park,
they're not like detailed kind of cool.
Look and monsters and you shoot out on with bows and arrows,
they're trying to invade the castle.
But man,
it's addictive because you really look down,
you see them all around you.
You have like a real,
so it was just that my always been my question about like,
you know,
I sit on my chair and I play my video game.
So like our,
yes,
this is it.
See this guy has a thing in his hands and he's moving around.
This is like a star wars one and there's a bunch of different ones that I've see
always gotta be standing right in some sense.
Yes,
you want to just like sit down with a borrower and like in a can,
but there's also a boxing one that you get a real workout in.
So it's a game.
And uh,
I played it over Duncan's house.
We think there's a video of it,
but it's,
it's weird because you punch wrong.
So like,
um,
like if I'm holding my hands like this,
which is,
I'm holding my hands vertically where my thumbs are up,
right.
The boxing gloves would be horizontal.
Like they would be if you were punching someone.
So,
so it doesn't do the turn.
No,
it's weird.
So as you move your hands forward like this,
which you really wouldn't punch like that,
then the punches come out.
So they've got to iron that out.
I was going to say that'll be something that'll work out.
Yeah.
And make the,
the,
the controller rotate the way a fist would.
But as you're doing it,
you throw real punches and someone's throwing punches at you and when they throw
punches at you and they hit you,
you see a white flash in front of the youth.
That's good.
Makes you nervous.
Just like real sparring does what the,
you know,
I mean,
so like this question of like what are we going to do with virtual reality?
Cause like I said,
you know,
I already,
I see huge potential for like education in gaming and that's why we built our
game.
Yeah.
Here's,
this is me over Duncan's house.
Just want anybody to walk by.
You know,
I got to go get a beer.
Bam.
I'm beating this guy up,
moving around them.
See that's the thing.
I always wonder,
that guy was fucking Duggin up every day.
It's like,
dude,
how'd you be it?
I was like,
move around.
Don't stand right in front of the rope.
The rope a dope.
Well,
you gotta,
you gotta have footwork and movement,
but you,
you can really get a workout with that.
I'm not joking.
You get exhausted and you know,
you,
you keep going and fight tougher and tougher opponents.
Well,
you know,
that's it.
And that's the quite,
you know,
so like talk about haptic suits,
like where eventually you know you're going to wear things.
I didn't see the,
I read the book but didn't see the,
what was it?
The movie that just ready,
set,
ready.
Player one I didn't see,
I didn't see you.
Have you read the book?
The book's really good because the book is like full immersion.
Like the whole book is about like when virtual reality is,
it.